Notice that we start with all the countries initially on the map and then
go year to year plotting the game of the World Cup as it changes host country.
And only showing the countries that were involved in that World Cup for
the given year.
So this is going through every year of the World Cup, in which there are twenty,
and plotting the home country's attendance numbers as an orange circle.
And every other participating country in the World Cup for
a given year is shown in light blue.
If the country did not participate in a given year of the World Cup,
this year being 2014, since it was the last World Cup, we simply make it white.